[Music]
so I want to thank you guys for all
coming today I appreciate you guys
taking the time to come out and see this
and today we're actually gonna talk
about the private catalog so this is
actually the first time we're actually
talking about this publicly we just
launched our Alpha last week and so I
want to talk to you about kind of what
we built and kind of why this might be
beneficial for your enterprise
so before we start actually wanna take a
quick survey how many of you here
actually consider yourselves like a
cloud IT admin cool all right we've got
a few
how about developers a few here
architects one two three four okay go
alright so this talk is actually going
to touch on most of that for the rest of
you here hopefully we'll have something
for you guys as well but basically well
we'll talk about what we're doing with
the private catalog so I'm gonna define
the private catalog the way we think
it's it should be it's to enable service
producers and cloud admins to control
distribution of solutions we want to
ensure internal compliance and
governance and we want solutions to be
discoverable within your enterprise and
of course easily deployable so the worst
control compliance governance
discoverable so those are the key things
I want you to take away from the session
today and those are the pillars that we
used in order to actually build the
private catalog so I'm gonna do things a
little differently instead of giving you
a bunch of slides of how great this is
and all the features and functionality
and everything I want to tell you a
little bit of story we're gonna walk
through it and show you how a fictional
enterprise might actually leverage the
private catalog all right so there's a
company called Acme game studio so Acme
has about 500 people they've been around
for a few years they've got a huge
market share on game development on
mobile devices so they develop four
i OS they evolved for Android when it
was falling the internal devices kind of
anything you can think of so these guys
basically have an IT environment where
they develop virtual machines for their
dev and test environments so the way it
works is a developer at Acme will go
find the right VM that they need to
develop their product or their feature
or their bug fixes so deploy that that
VM actually contains all the SDK tools
they're built tools integrations with
their bill lab everything's there so
then go ahead fix it then deploy the
test VM the test VMs got contained all
the emulators that they need in order to
actually test their bug fixes or their
features and if everything looks good
they'll go ahead and check it in and
shut down the machines that way they
don't spend a lot of money they don't
leave machines idle all the time and
that's kind of like the environment that
they are actually using so I want to
introduce Andy who is a cloud admin so
Andy is the guy at Acme that actually
manages those twenty virtual machines
within their enterprise so he noted the
Flies so he's one that updates them he
notifies all the developers when
everything has changed and so there's
new tools coming out all the time
there's patches coming out all the time
so he's updating constantly like every
few weeks he's changing things and
originally he was sending emails to
everyone when things change and so
emails get lost
he sends a lot emails as you guys know
developers then end up ignoring those
and then they kind of get lost and no
one knows what's going on next so he had
those lost support tickets he gets 30 to
40 a week and most of these tickets are
like where's the latest image just I
want to get my job done just where's my
latest image so he decided he's going to
create a wiki so any time he made the
update he updates the wiki he tells
everyone go to the wiki the wiki's have
a link to the latest and greatest
everyone was happy then he went on a
vacation his the guys taking over forgot
to update the wiki people started
deploying older images and then they ran
into the same problems over and over
so here's Darryl Darryl is a developer
at Acme he's been there for a couple
years loves the company loves the
culture just hates the tools he has no
idea like where things are at right like
he just wants to deploy the latest and
greatest he wants to be in compliance
with whatever the company said all the
rules all the government stuff like he
just doesn't want all that friction he
just wants to get his job done right and
so like you know whenever he needs a new
image he has no idea where to get it
like there's a bunch of emails floating
around there was a wiki there's no way
key anymore he doesn't know what's going
on right yes I asked around ask people
ask coworkers want a friend like he just
doesn't know what he needs to do so
Darryl basically just doesn't care he
just launches his VMs goes fixes his
bugs and they just keeps it running so
he's constantly causing a lot of money
to be wasted while this VMs are actually
just being left around and because the
tools keep getting updated a lot any
time he makes a change he checks it in
he's making a huge risk that he's gonna
break the build so when he does break
the build then he'll go find the right
VM go pull it for his change go test it
and then check that in causing a couple
of delays for everyone else blocking or
running the pipe so not really great so
does this sound familiar to you guys you
guys kind of handle this I see a lot of
nodding heads good all right so let's go
actually try to help Andy fix this so
I'm gonna actually do a demo of the live
bits I mentioned that we actually
shipped the Alpha last week so I'll be
running the real thing and show you guys
how Andy's gonna actually fix some of
these problems all right you guys switch
over
go alright so I'm actually logged in as
the add me act man sorry the Acne admin
and to get to the private catalog on the
left nav was the private catalog so what
you're seeing here is what we call the
zero state so you've got nothing in here
this is the private catalog there's
nothing for you to see because we
haven't added anything as an admin I
actually have a button here that says go
to catalog manager it's also on the left
here managed solutions so I'm actually
now in the admin console for the private
catalog so the first thing I want to do
is actually go and create a catalog so
what is the catalog our catalog is
really just a a grouping of the
solutions that you want to make
available to your end users so crania
catalog is actually really easy just
click on create catalog and just call
this dev tools tools for developers all
right so the name is actually important
because that's actually what we're gonna
show to your end-users and then
basically the description is just for
the admin itself so I'm actually
creating a catalog right now it's taking
a few seconds because this is real code
working in the back and the visibility
of catalogs actually depending on a few
things I'm actually gonna back up so
because I want to show you how multiple
catalogs interact with each other so let
me actually create one more catalog here
I just call this test tools so as this
is creating being created I mentioned
like visibility depends on a few things
one is when you create a catalog after
you're ready to make it visible to your
end-users you want to share it
somewhere in the GCP hierarchy and that
would be at the org level the folder
level or the project level then you need
to grant access to your users to that
org folder or project and that user will
also need an IM role to view catalogs so
those things all need to be in effect
before the end users can see it so as
the admin you control basically where
it's getting just
and then who has access to it all right
so I've created my two catalogs so
there's a dev tools and a test tools and
going in there basically I can add a
solution so we're in alpha we still have
a long ways to go but for our alpha we
have two prot two solution types that we
support the first is a link solution and
a link solution is really just a
reference link to anything it could be a
link to a terraform script it could be a
link to documentation it could be a link
to github repository so it's really
whatever you feel is should be available
to your end-users you can add that the
other one is a deployment manager
solution so for those I don't know what
deploy manager is deployment manager is
basically a way for you to kind of set
up a directive to deploy GCP first-party
content and so you can use deploy Imagi
to deploy VMs containers deploy a VM
with an auto scaling group and a little
balancer pretty much anything that GCP
can support so within my dev tools let
me go ahead and create a product so this
is going to be my android dev tools so
Android development tools with SDK I
think there are 29 I'm not sure where
they're at the tagline is the short
description that your end-users gonna
see in the little tile view so just call
this Android dev tools so I go ahead and
browse give me an icon here here's one
I've picked out
support information for your end users
so if they ran into problems don't know
who to contact
so I'll just say contact had been at
acne calm acne admin for the Creator so
the deploy magic template this is where
you would go ahead and point to the
template so let me kind of show you what
one of these templates look like so
here's why I created which has a zip
file when I open it up
and so one of the things I mentioned
earlier was control so how are you
actually gonna control what and where
your users are going to deploy these um
these solutions to so let me zoom in
here and so in my example here I'm going
to show you how to actually control what
machine type and what region the users
going to deploy to and so here we have
zone the property zone and we've got
machine type here so this is actually
going to set up a parameter as part of
the deployment experience so when the
end-users deploying this to the private
catalog they'll hash it be able to
select from a list that you as the admin
curated that you want them to deploy to
and the way that works is that there's a
schema file that you would include with
your deployment manager template and so
I mentioned others machine-type and zone
so you define it here where you'd have
your different machine types and then
the zones available so to show that this
is all real let's go ahead and actually
just limit these users to deploy to n1
standards and deploy to just one region
let's say US central alright so let me
save this and close it and I'm gonna zip
this up and then we'll actually use this
as part of the demo one gotcha is you do
need to name your deploy magic templates
the same name as the template file
itself we've got our diem friends down
here they can explain why later I'm not
sure why that's just a limitation we
have right now all right so I'm gonna go
ahead and browse that file I added and
here's the zip file and I'm gonna add so
that's pretty much it that's how you add
a solution to a private catalog so to
kind of make it look a little better
later I'm gonna go ahead and add an iOS
dev tools as well
that way at least it'll look pretty cool
when we actually have multiple products
in the catalog all right so here's the
iOS tools I can't use the other logo so
and I've got another zip file for iOS
cool all right so now I've added
basically two solutions to one catalog
for my private catalog and now I'm gonna
go to my test catalog and let me add a
link solution so let's just call this
the Android developer documentation
documentation
all right so Android the Ducks
so I'm gonna give this an icon here same
support information contacts I've been
I've been alright so here for your
reference links you just put in your
route anything so in this case -
pelipper
Android com so now I've added a link
solution to my test tools so I have
three a three solutions total so I
mentioned earlier visibility actually
requires a few things so it's sharing
the catalog somewhere in the GCP
hierarchy granting permissions to that
user to that location in the hierarchy
and making sure that end user has the
catalog view or I am role so let me go
ahead and share this catalog to a
project that I created earlier and I'm
going to share the second catalog - also
a project in my hierarchy now I'm gonna
go to the end-user view of the private
catalog so I'm at the org level which is
why you don't see anything right now so
if I go to the project level of where I
just shared those solutions - you can
actually see the three solutions that I
created alright so now let's go into one
of these Oh actually know before I go
there so basically you can see the
different catalog names that I entered
earlier so I mentioned that was
important because this is what your
end-users going to see so I can filter
by the catalogs and you can see the to
deploy magic templates I add it there I
can filter by the different types so
here's the deploy magic templates we've
got different the reference link itself
I can also search against the
description gets the product name this
will bring down or show me kind of
what's there and then if I go into one
of these basically this is the detail
page for the content I created so you're
probably wondering this looks a lot like
the Google cloud marketplace and it does
because we actually are reusing the same
components on the front end and the back
end in fact we're actually the same team
built the marketplace let's put in the
private catalog
so in here I want to go to the length if
I click here it will just take me to a
reference link so if you're not
deploying to play manage your template
you want to use this again you can point
to documentation point to github
repository point to terraform scripts
whatever you'd like and then on the tool
side so I can go ahead and actually
launch this VM that I actually added
earlier so the first thing I need to do
is basically here's my contest
alright so here's the parameter so you
saw me earlier actually delete those
items inside the zip file and so now as
an end user can imagine they're coming
in here I want to deploy this VM and I
can only choose these machine types and
these zones so your end users can't go
deploy in like the biggest possible
beefiest machine and waste a ton of
resources and money and they can't
deploy to different regions because
you're limiting to kind of what they can
do here so I'll just go ahead and choose
the Machine type and zone hit deploy
this goes through the regular deployment
manager experience and then this will
just go ahead and deploy and go through
alright so I'm gonna go back to the
slides the guys can help me switch back
all right
cool alright so I just showed you how
easy it was to actually go create a
catalog go add content to it and then
make it visible to your users so
basically from a discoverability
perspective it's really easy for people
to know what's available because they
just go to this end user console for
governance and compliance you as a admin
make sure that your users are deploying
the latest and greatest that you're
making available and then from a control
perspective you saw how I basically put
in guardrails
so those end-users can't go ahead and
deploy willy-nilly on any machine types
or any regions that they want and
because it's all parameterizing it's
through a deployment manager you could
change those parameters to whatever you
want I mean you can set up different
ranges for auto scaling groups you can
different parameters you can set up
different Ram types that you want them
to deploy as well so all that
configuration control is up to you as
the admin best of all this is gonna be
free so we're not gonna charge you for
this this is gonna come out you can just
use this in your enterprise we want you
to deploy more GCP solutions alright but
this is actually going to be free so
let's take a little bit into like the
the four pillars I mentioned earlier so
discoverability so when you have someone
new to your team someone that just
transferred over something new that you
hired I think it's great to just say go
here and deploy all the approved
solutions for you this is a single tool
so I've talked to several customers in
the last few months as we were building
this and I asked them explicitly what do
I used today like how do people discover
stuff in your enterprise and I've heard
everything from wiki's emails notepad
documents spreadsheets Word docs it's
kind of all over so we're kind of like
getting rid of all that here's a single
place I showed the searching filtering
so you can filter by the solution type
by the different catalogs and then as an
end user if you have access to multiple
catalogs you'll see a union of all that
information which I showed earlier where
you had two catalogs and you actually
saw everything that I shared to that
project
so for internal compliance and
governance this is all about your
end-users right so your end-users want
to know that they're always deploying
the latest and greatest they don't want
to think about it they don't want that
friction right they want to be confident
they're deploying the latest best
blessed solutions that you as the IT
admin has put in there so they want to
know that they've deployed all the
latest security patches right I mean
here's a big thing right now
there's new patches coming on there's
vulnerabilities happening all the time
images get updated they don't have to
worry about that because you're putting
up the latest and greatest every company
has its own policies again they want to
make sure that wherever they employed
someone has approved so they're not
gonna even think about it
and then for compliance if you have a
lot of vm's a lot of solutions and you
need to basically update them
we have API to allow you to actually do
bulk updates so control so sharing of
the catalogs at the GCP hierarchy at the
organization folder or project level so
visibility depends on that end user
having access to that hierarchy and
having the I am role so for talking
about I am roles so we have an I am role
for admins as well so you don't have a
bottleneck you don't just have one
person so you can have multiple admins
manage and curate the your catalog and
the products themselves so I mentioned
earlier the guardrails so you can put up
guardrails make sure people aren't
deploying machines that they shouldn't
be deploying to that they're actually
deploying to the regions that you're
limiting them to you can add round
spinning groups anything you want and
then only the admins can add content to
the private catalog so admins are
controlling what actually gets to be
there and what your end-users are going
to see so this kind of highlights that
deon template again I don't know it's
kind of hard to see on that little
notepad document I had earlier but what
I've highlighted here is basically how
you would actually go ahead and define
the guardrails within your deploy magic
template and then inside the schema file
this is where you would enumerate the
different combinations of things
that the users would be able to get to
so let's talk a little bit about the API
s so we built the api's first we built
it with the product itself it wasn't an
afterthought and we do have admin API as
for all the crud operations so creation
update deletion and so this is great for
basically bulk updating of your content
we have end-user api's as well and so
this is allowing you to query for what
your user actually has access to and so
this would be useful for basically
enterprises that currently potentially
have their own solution right now and
want to include cloud software or let's
say you had ServiceNow in your
enterprise and you don't wanna get rid
of that but you do want to include GCP
content so you could use it end user API
is to check what the logged in user has
access to and then query for that and
then for deployment basically you can
leverage the deployment manager api's
which are currently public and there's
these slides will be available later so
there's a link to it to the deployment
manager api's so end-user query API is
we've got catalogs where you can list
and get catalogs you can do products you
can do versions on the admin side we've
got catalogs so you can go create the
catalogs you can update couch and delete
catalogs you can I think we have an
undelete catalog as well if you screw up
so we have identity so you can kind of
check what the identity of the user is
and what role is that they have we have
a so station this is why I called
sharing earlier so this is basically API
is to create the cat and we share the
catalog with some part of the GCP
hierarchy then of course the the
products and version api's as well for
your solutions so I want to give you an
example of kind of how you can use these
api's so let's say you actually had a CI
CD solution to build these VMs and so it
exists today you've got maybe a github
repository you've got some scripts and
so anytime someone actually makes an
update there's a process that gets
kicked off that basically generates a
new vm deploys those scripts onto the vm
runs little scripts
and you can integrate with that process
that you can only have and call the
private catalog api's which then will
allow you to then update that solution
inside your private catalog for your end
users that way you've got that full
lifecycle
everything works it's this full solution
and your users again don't have to care
about that they're always going to be
deploying the latest and greatest so so
we launched our alpha last week this was
actually a good sprint we've actually
worked on it for only about six months
so what do we have today so we have that
UX experience that you saw for the end
user and for the admin so we have our
API so where you do crowd operations on
the product and on the catalog
we've got api's for end-users for any
integrations that you may want into your
own homegrown solution or something like
a ServiceNow or anything out there we
basically allow you to create multiple
catalogs so it's up to you on how you
wanted to find how your catalogs should
work like it could be a catalog just for
developers it could be a catalog for a
certain platform it could be a catalog
just for your legal department whatever
you want all right but you can create as
many calories as you want there's no
limits there so you can basically have I
am rows to allow other admins to go and
manage those catalogs and those
solutions so we support two content
types today so there's the reference
links and deployment manager templates
and so our goal is of course is to
continue adding to this and add more
solution types so there's a single point
of entry for your admins and your end
users and basically the IM permissions
will gate whether they have access to
the admin console or not so that kind of
simplifies so everyone just goes to a
single place so we integrate the DM
experience which looks exactly like the
cloud launcher so you kind of have the
same flows so anyone familiar with the
cloud marketplace we actually just
change the name so anyone familiar with
the GCP cloud marketplace can just
follow that same path and then if you
have any org policies set with your
organization or D and if you use the
damn constraints we're going to respond
all that we're not gonna override
anything so all that kind of works well
within the GCP environment so I want to
give you guys an opportunity to
influence our roadmap so we have just
shipped an alpha and so we have a lot of
ideas of what we want to do next and how
we want to make this bigger and better
but we want to make it so that it's
something that's enticing to you that
you want to use and that you're going to
deploy in your enterprise and so one way
you can help us and influence our
roadmap is to actually go take the
survey and so actually if can you just
flip to the the next to my machine all
right so we've got a max diff survey
here that I'd love for you guys to kind
of just take and basically it's ten
questions it's got a list a bunch of
features that were thinking of actually
adding and so all you need to do is like
yeah this is the least important this is
the most important on each one of these
no take about five ten minutes but the
data you give us is going to be really
valuable because then it'll actually
help us understand kind of like what are
the things that you do need in your
enterprise to make this actually really
useful and valuable so it'll be a great
partnership for you kind of just help
take the survey all right can you guys
flip back cool all right so G dot co /
cloud / private catalog survey all right
all right so we're in alpha it's not
publicly available but it is available
so we want you guys to try it out
so cloud guru column / private catalog
signup so it's a really simple form give
me your name email company title and
then we'll get your white listed so you
can try it out we've got a ton of
documentation we're very Road so kind of
walk through the scenario that I
presented earlier we even documented as
well so you can kind of follow the same
steps and things that I've done we've
got a getting started guide a QuickStart
guide as well so try it out Russ
basically go to go to the cloud Google
comet catalog slash sign up and then
basically a status information we'll get
you hooked up all right and then if you
guys have any feedback private - catalog
- feedback at Google calm so
let us know if you if there are any
features you think are missing if you
have any comments things like that I'm
on this alias a bunch of the team is on
it as well this is a great way for you
to kind of get in direct contact with us
and again we want to build this thing so
that you guys can use it right like
we're building this for you to kind of
help you with your enterprise and so
we'd love to partner with you guys to
make sure that we're building the great
but basically a great piece of software
that you do want to leverage it use
alright so with that I am done so
[Applause]
[Music]
you